aux yeux comme vous êtes branché cette
mesure va permettre d'accompagner vers
la métropole
les habitants de la martinique de la
guadeloupe et de la heg en france nous a
fait croire qu y avait de la place pour
nous mon père était un vieux [ __ ] en
colère l'adar miros et ça m'inquiète pas
parce que je me disais si tu trouves pas
ta place dans la société
tu la trouveras pas dans ma propre
famille j'ai pu me chercher ne croire en
plus ma poche trouée
c'était fait une bonne dizaine de
bureaux de poste je me sentais comme un
smicard jaud plus besoin demandez je
voulais plus du petit doigt l'état je
vous laisse hamad tout entière en un
sens c'est jusqu'au bout ça va mal finir
répartis dans le temps
je sais d'où tu viens
je voudrais pouvoir t'aider
ce confiance aux blancs toi arrête
jamais il ya d'autres façons de gagner
d'argent pas ici faire toi de régler ça
tu as le choix
tu vas finir en prison dit
pourquoi d'aller se faire ça
chérèque
maintenant